we welcome you back to CBS mornings we
have new information on how Brittany
Greiner is doing in a Russian prison and
we've learned about one of her greatest
fears we spoke with her wife shirelle
Griner an inclusive interview it's been
nearly eight months since shirelle saw
Brittany who she affectionately calls BG
all of her friends call her that the
WNBA All-Star and Olympic gold medalist
has been in Russian custody since
February she was sentenced to nine years
in prison after less than a gram of
cannabis oil and vape cartridges was
found in her luggage at a Moscow airport
her appeal will be heard by a Russian
Court later this month shirelle Griner
fears that if Britney is not released
before then she may be moved to a labor
camp we went to the Griner home in
Phoenix two days ago to speak with
shirelle this is her first interview
since Brittany was sentenced in August
now as you know Brittany Greiner has
been described as unlawfully detained
Sherelle Greiner has another word for it
on his face it just seems like my wife
is a hostage to know that our government
and the foreign government is sitting
down and negotiating for her release
she's a hostage shirelle Griner is in
the fight of her life to bring her wife
Brittany Greiner home a recent meeting
at the White House reassured her that
President Biden is also fighting for
Britney's release I feel as if
his own Merit he's doing what he can but
there's another party in this situation
and we also are dealing with the need
for Russia to have mercy on BG as well
what do you believe that it will take to
bring her home now I feel like at this
point it's going to take
Putin to have that same mindset and say
you know what
Brittany Greiner who came to my country
for seven eight years and helped my
country be recognized through sport pay
taxes in my country help my country I'm
gonna sit at a table and I'm going to be
clear about what I need in return for
her release so that we can actually get
a meeting of the months between these
two governments in February authorities
found .7 grams of cannabis oil in
Brittany greiner's possession at a
Moscow airport I have heard so many
stories about this exact situation
happening with Americans going through
Russia and at the airport they were told
pay a fine and then go on by your day
but because BG is Brittany Greiner I do
think that this got really complicated
really quickly the six nine basketball
player has a prescription for medical
cannabis in her own State Arizona for
chronic pain in Russia no amount of
marijuana is legal I work in the legal
field I do believe a crime
should warrant a punishment you should
be held accountable balance it must be
balanced and that it tears me to pieces
to see that this is not balanced for my
wife right now and so I want people to
see that to see the fact that like has
she suffered enough like BG has truly
suffered Beyond her crime already
communication between shirelle and her
wife has been very limited they were not
able to talk on the phone until August
that six months after Brittany was
arrested so you were able to hear her
voice you've had two phone conversations
with her share with us what you can
about those conversations so the first
conversation it was just so delightful
just to hear her voice at that point I
was like you know what
I think she's okay we can we can we can
survive this the second phone call
I just
the minute I hung up I think I cried for
about two three days straight I did not
get out of my bed it was the most
disturbing phone call I'd ever
experienced
um and I've known BG 11 years and so I'm
like that was the most disturbing what
was disturbing to you it was her like
you could you could you could hear it
like you could hear that she was not
okay you know if you think about just a
person suffering and when they have
suffered to a Max like you could hear
that like she was at the max that day
and I'm like God and there was nothing I
could do you know so I'm sitting there
and I'm just like
it was like 30 seconds to two minutes of
range for just sitting on the phone just
literally in tears just crying and it's
just the most still
I think moment I've just ever shared
with my wife I didn't have words because
at that point I'm like I don't know if
she has anything left in her tank to
continue to wake up every day and be in
a place where she has no one shirelle is
hoping that a prisoner swap between the
United States and Russia will happen
before an October 25th appeal hearing
what could happen to Brittany in two
weeks
in my brain I'm like please in two weeks
have figured this out
um but
the reality of the situation is that
once that hearing is held and the order
is finalized VG's now in the position
where she could be moved to a labor camp
and
I
my brain can't even fathom it Brittany
Greiner has been playing professional
basketball in Russia since 2014. when
you think of bgm basketball you're going
to obviously connect the dot back to
Russia I mean she she was excited to go
play there shirelle showed us where she
keeps some of Britney's most precious
metals I look at the Shelf though it
really has her two worlds that's Russian
MVP correct and then you see her gold so
it's her two worlds right here in this
in your office like that's I mean that's
her life when I look at the news and I
don't know her of course and most people
who are watching this don't know her she
looks very vulnerable to me in the tape
when you see her what do you see
she's not herself when I see her she's
not herself I say she's strong because
how are you still standing like how are
you still alive going through this but
veggies are absolute weakest moment in
life right now she's very afraid about
being left and forgotten in Russia or
just completely used
to the point of her detriment because
she's like you know saying things to me
like
my life just don't even matter no more
is that what you said to you yeah I feel
like my life just doesn't matter like
you guys like y'all don't see me like
y'all don't see the need to get me back
home
um and by just nothing like
and those are all valid emotions to feel
and I don't have answers for it except
the fact that your life matters to me
and I want to get you back home and I'm
going to continue to pray every day that
you know the people that are the
decision makers in this situation will
have mercy and we'll sit down and they
will too see that your life matters and
do whatever they can to agree
um on terms
that's what we all hope shirelle this
week the White House said that it has a
substantial deal on the table right now
and urge Russia to consider it or bring
a strong counter-offer official won't
officials are not saying of course what
that offer is but it does include we're
told a potential prisoner swap for
Russian arms dealer Victor boot in
exchange for Griner an American Paul
Whelan we haven't forgotten about him
either but you know my heart of course
goes out to shirelle imagine your loved
one has been eight months you get a five
minute phone call a 15-minute phone call
that's very arbitrary they just decide
you don't know when it's coming you
don't know when your next phone call is
going to be breaking on the other end of
the phone she's very very concerned
about her mentally they don't think
she's being harmed physically but
they're very concerned about how much
longer she can take you know and
Brittany greiner's her birthday is
October 18th she'll be 32 and they're
all hoping that she will be out by her
birthday but it's very scary because
it's so arbitrary yeah and those notes
of Despair and the shirelle described
that's very worrying right it's one
thing to be locked up but then you're
locked up abroad yes people are speaking
a foreign language yes it's all
exacerbated by all of these small little
layers where the loneliness anxiety the
fear the pain and she said Brittany
didn't even know what was happening when
she was taken into custody they're
speaking Russian she signs a document
she didn't really know what it was and
when you look at the case you know it's
the residue from The Vape cartridges
that I was told guys is less is the size
of a raisin so it's not like she had a
lot it's a non-issue it's obviously you
know a political she is a political Pond
right this uh I hope Sherelle can get a
message to her somehow that the world
does care and the U.S does care and
people are paying attention that's one
reason why she wanted to do the
interview even when I was going to
Arizona and they said why are you here
to talk to about Brittany grinder well
who's that someone actually said that to
me it's top of mind for a lot of people
but a lot of people still do not know
this name and they want to keep her name
front and so Paul wheel in there as well
of course exactly right